I heard you're not supposed to eat three
hours before bed and so what I did was I
came home and ate like the equivalent of
four dinners right before bed so you
know not always making the best
decisions as I sat there eating supper
at 10 36 PM I was sitting there watching
shorts and what I realized was while I
loved a lot of the content the YouTube
algorithm was serving me I was impartial
to who the content was coming from I
wasn't looking at the Channel I didn't
subscribe to anybody I was just swiping
consuming having subscribers is cool but
it doesn't matter if they don't care
about you as a person especially in a
world of short form content where
viewers are one swipe away from moving
on to someone else